[Music]
on a day that had the potential to seal
Cyril ramaphosa's fate supporters of the
embattled South African president came
out to sing his praises
as the executive committee of the ruling
African National Congress met to discuss
findings from an independent panel that
Mr ramaphosa may have violated his oath
of office these members of the ANC had
their own message
but not everyone in this small crowd was
there to express support
for the sake of saving our party the
party of our people the party that we
love Mr ramaphosa
Mr ramaphosa who showed up to recuse
himself from the proceedings is in the
middle of an ever-growing political
Scandal that's been dubbed farm gate
it concerns the theft of at least five
hundred and eighty thousand dollars from
palapala his private game farm and
allegations that Mr ramaphosa attempted
to cover it up
for days it was unclear if the anc's top
leaders would back Mr ramaphosa or ask
him to step down but after hours of
deliberations that question was finally
answered let the president continue with
his responsibilities
until such time that all these processes
requires that he can continue
Mr ramaphosa who continues to deny any
wrongdoing has filed court papers
challenging the findings of the
independent panel's report
some analysts believe the anc's
leadership ultimately decided to support
Mr ramaphosa not because they believe
he's innocent but because there are no
credible Alternatives there is currently
no untainted contestant for leadership
of the party and so they're deciding to
back Mr ramaphosa largely because of
both the political and economic Fallout
that might result if they went ahead
with an impeachment process Parliament
was originally set to meet on Tuesday
debate the panel's findings and
potentially vote on setting up an
impeachment procedure but that session
has been postponed by a week and since
the ANC has the majority of seats in
Parliament president ramaphosa who's
been assured of his party's backing may
now have a lot less to worry about
Johannesburg